when stepping back and thinking about it
it is kind of odd that as the human
species we take possession of other
types of species and call them our pets
and it is even order that it is accepted
as normal across essentially all of
humanity we take animals that cannot
communicate with us on any real coherent
level bring them into our homes call
them our pets and live with them we feed
them shelter them and take care of them
and generally all we ask in return is
that we just get to be around them but
why is this what is so appealing about
sharing our life with another species
outside of more practical reasons like
assisting in hunting gathering and
general tasks one reason for
assimilating pets is the human desire to
have responsibility and control the need
to feel important and the need to feel
like something is dependent on us this
feeling is empowering and as humans our
central insecurities are partly satiated
by the sense of superiority we
experience when owning and domesticating
another living being on the surface
this might sound somewhat feeble and
selfish of us humans but the truth is
although this may be a motive there is a
much deeper and more sincere reason why
we like owning and being around our pets
a reason that makes the relationship
between human and animal companion a
truly mutual interdependent and
beautiful one that reveals a wonderful
side of our nature
we do not simply own our pets we love
them we become best friends with them
and form bonds that are truly reciprocal
and unconditional we give them access to
consistent safety health comfort and
other logistical things that they might
struggle to sustain and in return they
help remind us of a side of ourselves
that we want so deeply to live in but
often struggle with the appreciation for
simplicity the ability to feel free the
obsession with fun the lack of
sensitivity to embarrassment the
disinterest in holding grudges and the
unrestrained affection that our pets
possess our all of the things that we
long for and wish we could feel
constantly in ourselves but often
struggle to do so and our pets embody
and remind us of the importance and
possibility of these things I would
argue that the elements of our nature
that our pets lack like complex language
logical understanding heightened
self-awareness etc are all equally
beautiful and essential to what makes
the human experience so uniquely
wonderful that I would also argue that
it can be very easy to become lost in
this part of ourselves the part that
needs to understand and control
everything
and our animal companions help show us
that we don't always need to that life
can sometimes be best enjoyed by simply
enjoying it for what it is
feeling it playing in it rolling in its
grass and so perhaps at the end of the
day even though we may like to think
that our pets depend on us it may be
more so the other way round thank you
for watching if you found enjoyment and
value in this video please give it a
thumbs up share your thoughts in the
comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder